có khoảng 5.5 kêu cú trong tình trạng đã xe dựng từ 8.5 kêu lên.
Tất cả đều đã xuống cấp.
Điện nơi rất tự xuy trở, cười nơi gầy mất ăn toàn, ăn gưởng đến bị quan đồ thị.
Được khi có chủ trường cải tạo chung cú cú, nơi rất tải cua tập thêm,
mới làm xe trên khánh dư rất đồng thuật.
Huyện vọng lời nhất của nơi rất tải đầy,
lần được tải đình cư tải chố mới dựng tích sự dụng được tăng thêm.
Cải tạo lại chung cú cú, lắm một trong những yên tiên lớn của phường cử năm,
hướng tiếp cận màn tính nhân văn nó là phát triển nhờ thứ mạnh ngày tải cua cải tạo.
Nhưng yên tiên bán cho chính các phổ dân đang xin xuống tại nó.
Dạy pháp này rất các rà định nhiều thế hệ trong những các phổ chất hẹp khoảng 4.5 mất buôn.
Có cơ hội cải thiển khu răng sống.
Phương án, người dân chỉ sẽ được tải đình cư tải chố.
Phương án điên bụi đàn bảo theo ký trình tự thủ tục quy định của các loch.
Và phường luôn là ngay ký thủ hiệm khu ngồi dân trong các trình thử thiện khai giữa án đi đàn bảo.
Tốt rất quyền lợi. Nhưng người dân.
Để văn giật thăng ra, giữa án phải có hiệu quả tinh tế.
Giờ nó, việc tăng tân cao tăng dựng tích sản hoặc tăng số lượng các khổ thương này.
Lạv văn đề xuất phổ dân giật.
Vừa 2 hoa lợi ý của các bên, nhưng không để khoa tải mất độ dân số.
Lạv văn đề được thành phố lên phương án với từng chung cú cú.
Vì văn giận thành phố sẽ xây dựng tự chí trong cải tạo trung khu cú, theo hướng điều trình quy đất.
Giờ dành một phần đáng kể cho không trình cầu cầu không.
Không gián sinh hoa cộng đồng và các việc íc phục uống người dân thay vì tận dụng tối đà từng mất vôn.
Để xây dựng nhận.
Bà mấy toàn ra, tại thành sôn nữa nào.
Lễm mà chúng ta kai thiết tự pho ăn vộ khu cộng đỏ.
Thì không nhất thiết là phải xây dựng tỏng vộ về địa phích của cả.
Để mà làm cái thông trình không cậu.
Để không ra, mà có anh cái phần còn nào.
Hãy được lói chúng ta với tài thiết, tài định cơ tài chố trong người dân.
Cũng như là tạo video kẹt, tài thiết dân nhận.
Hãy đầu cư trong tài, xây dựng tụng khu cộ tài.
Còn lợi giỏi đẹh học, cùng trung xức quy đời khẩn phố trong lập tài thiết, là các cú cộng.
Nhất là cái cú cộng của chúng tôi.
Còn lợi giỏi đẹh dựng tụng khu cộng.
Tại tạo chung cơ cố, không chỉ là thay những tài nhà cố, vằng những tài nhà mới.
Mặc còn là kiến tạo những khu càng sống tốt hơn.
Bởi đây đủ cộng trình khu cộng.
Cây xanh, trường học, mái đổ xe và hạ tân đồng bộ để nâng cao chất lượng cuộc sống của người dân.
Nó cũng là giá trị lâu dài trong quá trình, tại thiết lâu thiết, mà thành phố hà nội cần hử dưới.